hey everybody eight seven and today I'm
really excited because I want to share
with you a tool that I love using the
saves my business a ton of time and I
don't think I've talked about it before
so it's called sign now I'm gonna log in
and show you guys what it all looks like
and it's a free service I don't know
about you guys but I hate paperwork I
hate paperwork so much I hate having to
get faxes and fax things back and forth
and you can't read anything and being
there by the fax machine I just hate it
and you're stuck with all these papers
lying around your house in your office
and there's just too much and so
side.now solves that problem and
basically what it allows you to do is
upload any document that you need to
have signed and it can have your
signature there and you can type in on
top of it and it's exports and saves it
as a PDF that you can share with
wherever you need to send it to so here
are some examples either some things
that I used for this was a speaker thing
a gig that I had to speak game this was
a clothing deal I'm working on another
speaker gig and other speaker gig and so
they send me contracts that I have to
sign to say hey you know I'm gonna show
up and be a speaker and I commit to
doing this and again instead of printing
it out and signing it and faxing it and
wasting all that time I can just upload
it to sign now for free and add my
signature and add in whatever
information I need and we're good to go
it saves me so much time so I'm gonna do
a quick example I can't load up these
contracts I don't think for
confidentiality reasons but I'm gonna
just go find one it doesn't really
matter let's do a contract PDF and let's
pull up what's the sample contract so
this is just some sample contract I have
no idea who this company is but this is
usually the part here where you have to
fill in your name put in your title so
I'm just gonna download this I'll save
it and you'll see how easy it is so I'll
save this to my desktop example contract
so this is typical it's gonna happen
right you get something sent to you you
have to sign so you log into your sign
now I'm gonna click on the upload button
I'm gonna go find it sample contract and
what's gonna happen is gonna upload it
for me
so it's opening the file it's gonna send
it to their servers and here it is
sample contract so I can either open it
right now and add my own signature or
canned also I think this is a paid
version if you want to invite other
people to sign it through their system
so I'm only on the free version so click
open it's gonna load the page for me and
show me exactly what it looks like and
this is the same as it is here and if
you have to go out and find out where I
need to add information in so a couple
cool things one is the signature so you
can add in your own signature so part of
the settings is you can either upload a
signature or you can try to draw your
own signature in and then once you do
that again that's free just click my
signature wherever you need to sign it
you put it here it loads my signature
and I can drag it to the right spot and
I can make it bigger or smaller whatever
I need for the size right there and then
I can go add text if I want to so if I
want to put you know so that's my
signature I'm gonna put my name type in
Carmichael title founder of Evan
Carmichael comm and again I can oops I
can move this around to make it fit I
can add the date if there's a date field
so I can put that in here if I wanted to
I can do a check mark so I think up here
somewhere there were little check boxes
oh so this is asking for a date so this
like 10th day of whatever so I could put
in I can go back to my text and put in
the number 10 or if I wanted I can add a
check mark and it adds checked so depend
on what you have to fill out and again
everything you can just move to make it
fit so this is super helpful at least
for me I find like I've done this
contract in two minutes I click done so
I'll say I'm done not know if there's
anything else here but this is a fake
contract anyway but I can do it multiple
times or I can add in my signature
wherever you need to especially when
you're doing like real estate deals man
you need a lot of signatures a lot of
initials so you could just pop that in
there really quickly you click done
it saves it here it is now the sample
contract and my main options here is I
can either download or email a copy
usually I'll just download it to my
desktop and then send it off to the
email so if I download here it's gonna
come in sample contract and I can open
it and then we see that's what it's
gonna look like ten checkmark I've
signed it it looks official right the
name the text the date everything this
is great and so signed huge deals just
using sign now and I've got an awesome
PDF that I can save on file whenever I
need it the whole all my PDFs are saved
here the history so I can always go back
and get something else if I want to and
there are a few bonus things that you
can do I guess if you want to make it as
a template if you're gonna do it
ongoing and these are paid upgrades that
you can use I don't know how much it
cost to upgrade I never use those
features but I love it anyway I hope
this helps save you time it saves me a
lot of time you can check it out it's
sign now calm I have no affiliation with
this company other than I love using
their stuff and it saves me a lot of
time so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please give it a thumbs
up below let me know what you think in
the comments as well and if you have a
question for me about your business or
about a website or technology or how I
do something leave it in the comments
below I make a video reply thank you so
much
and I'll see you soon